Oh
Oh
you
in these two works that were looking at
here the letter from a Birmingham jail
and the I have a dream speech Martin
Luther King is going to talk at many
points about non-violence as the means
to try to achieve what is calling racial
justice the response too long in ransom
ated and perpetuated conditions of
injustice of inequality of exploitation
and what we want to look at in this
portion is how he's framing what is
telling us about the workings of
nonviolent resistance so he talks much
more about this in the the letter from a
Birmingham jail so much of the the
quotations and discussions are going to
be from there but there is an important
passage in the I have a dream speech
that we'll talk about and you notice
I've got two things here one is sort of
a list of the the parts of a campaign
that he talks but really on in the jail
letter and then I've got this diagram
here that's having to do with the power
structure with the attention that's
underlying it and will be will be
visiting that in some detail in a few
minutes so early on in his speech he
says in a non-violent campaign there's
four basic steps so nonviolent
resistance at least the way that Martin
Luther King conceives of it isn't
something that just spontaneously
happens you know there's some oppression
and people say oh we got to do something
about this it actually takes some some
thinking out some coordination there's a
method to it that's not to say there
isn't any spontaneity involved there's
no reacting to local circumstances
there's no improvisation because this is
actually as he says creative and its
workings it's it's a manifesting a
different kind of creativity but
something that's more akin to what is
going on with the artist response to his
or her material and you know trying to
work out classic themes like that
offering injustice and less like some
sort of you know textbook here's exactly
how it's done doctrinaire approach he
says the first thing you have to do is
actually collect facts before deciding
that well we should have some resistance
we should actually collect facts to see
whether indeed injustice is being
committed he says we have to determine
whether in justices exists so not every
situation is a situation right we're
ready for non-violent action as a matter
of fact there could be plenty of times
where people are calling for nonviolent
protests were no real injustice is
existing in this case he says it's
pretty clear that in Birmingham there is
injustice as a matter of fact in the
whole of the south and the whole of the
United States at that time there is
injustice but particularly in Birmingham
so we're not going to talk anymore about
collecting the facts but that is
something important to point out that
that King doesn't think that this is a
technique or a method that you just
apply to every sort of situation
dogmatically thinks that you have to go
on a case-by-case basis then there's
negotiation and what he's talking about
as negotiation you should think of in
terms of presenting demands in terms of
trying to call people's attention to
what sort of abuses are taking place it
requires instead of simply you know
going out and protesting that one
actually try to work within the system
that exists try to reach out to the
people that one can contact and say look
what's wrong here why are you doing this
why are you tolerating this why are you
imposing this on other people don't you
understand that this is the wrong thing
to do so this is a key element in any
sort of nonviolent protest and any sort
of non-violent action before you get to
the marches the boycotts all that sort
of stuff there has to be talking and now
notice what this involves this has to be
dialogue King talks at a certain point
about the south is having been run and
too long by a monologue
not giving way to genuine dialogue the
oppressed in this model actually have to
make some sort of effort to reach out to
the oppressor and say what you're doing
is wrong here is how it's wrong here's
why it's wrong why don't you stop it why
don't you fix this they have to treat in
short the oppressor as if the oppressor
is not just an evil person or some sort
of mechanism or robot inflicting
penalties and punishments and you know
inequalities everywhere just you know
for the sake of doing so but it is an
actual human agent somebody who is
capable of making a decision to leave
behind wrong and evil and turn towards
good and justice after that King says
then you have these two freight these
two parts of the the the procedure
self-purification the protesters in the
South who are working with the
nonviolent civil rights movement
actually underwent quite a lot of
training why did they undergo this sort
of training because the leadership
didn't want anyone out there who was
going to lose their cool under terrible
pressure and suddenly start acting in
ways that would give the the white
police a chance to retaliate there that
all has to do with what's going on down
here the self purification has to do for
preparation for a conflict with genuine
evil where one knows that one is going
to be hurt where there's a potentiality
even for losing one's life where one has
already been been treated as lacking in
dignity so you know he says no we've
gone through these steps in Birmingham
we you know we realized that after
negotiation had broken down we had no
alternative to
but to prepare for direct action and he
says we would present a very bodies as a
means of laying our case before the
conscience of the local and national
community mindful of the difficulties
involved we decided to undertake a
process of self purification what did
that consistent we began a series of
workshops on non-violence we repeatedly
asked ourselves are you able to accept
lowes without retaliating are you able
to endure your deal of jail and those
who were not able to do that couldn't be
part of the protest movement why not
because if you're going to as he says if
we're going to present our bodies as a
means of laying our case before the
conscience of the national community
that is subject oneself as a bodily
being as a physical being to the
brutality to the violence of other
people so that the national community
and the local community can see it and
say this is wrong this shouldn't be
happening one has to be able to at least
appear not to be the aggressor not to be
retaliating in kind we'll talk about why
that's so important bit later so then we
get to the fourth phase which is direct
action notice that again a lot of people
want to jump right here King says if
you're actually going to be engaging in
nonviolent you know action you have to
do this you have to do this you have to
do this first you can't simply go on to
direct action there are conditions that
that govern whether one can do that
because the direct action will not be
effective entertaining its purposes if
you don't actually go through these
stages now he tells us some very
interesting and important and
distinctive things about the nature of
nonviolent direct action one is that I
didn't actually put up here on the board
he says this is in response to the
religious leaders and say why aren't you
just focused on negotiation King says
direct action is actually supposed to
leave
back to negotiation it's not done for
its own sake it's actually a means to an
end and this is actually a means to
another end the ultimate end is racial
justice that's the far-off you know eyes
on the prize prize to be seeking the
immediate n is a you know bettering and
improvement of conditions and a
recognition of the injustice of the the
conditions preceding it that comes
ultimately through negotiation but in
many cases that can only happen with
direct action why because as we've seen
as he talks about it's very rare that
those who are involved in oppressing
others those who are benefiting from an
unjust arrangement of society are going
to suddenly say yeah let's let's fix
this there are a very few cases you know
where that's happened in history but
usually it takes some sort of
catalyzation some sort of changing of
perspective in order for that to happen
and the way that perspective changes is
by people talking and people doing
things that send a message or send
several messages so what else does he
say directly action has to be carried
out in a spirit of love and nonviolent
protest so let's talk about this for a
bit what does it mean to loved ones
enemies because that's what he's talking
about here the Christian injunction to
turn the other cheek to loved ones
enemies to not retaliate to not give in
to anger does it mean that one has to
have warm fuzzy feelings towards one's
enemy that one has to you know get them
things on Valentine's Day no we're
talking about a very different
conception of love here which means to
choose to do to exhibit goodness towards
those who are bad to bless those who
curse you is one
the injunctions went a person who can
actually do that sets a very powerful
model that can quite often break through
the long sedimented structures that that
keep people compartmentalized into this
type and this type in this type and I'm
not going to deal with you because
you're over here and you're no good but
it takes a lot to be able to do that it
requires a commitment that gets made
over and over and over again and every
time that the other person behaves like
a jerk towards you or even worse behaves
like a tyrant a bully and a presser a
murderer even towards you it's a new
challenge to be able to do that that's
why this self purification was so
centrally important they would actually
practice getting mistreated some of the
people roleplay so that they could
handle it when they encountered it
nonviolent protests this means not
throwing bottles not throwing bricks not
resisting those who are actually going
to be using violence against them and in
this case in Birmingham it was you know
sending police dogs against people to
bite them to you know to attack them it
was spraying them with fire hoses and
fire hoses meant you know very high
pressure water that could take a person
and just throw them against a wall you
know or could actually take off skin at
the pressure that they were pumping it
through it meant you know police batons
it meant in some cases being shot so
nonviolent protest means standing up and
saying this is wrong that over there is
wrong what you're doing here is wrong
but I'm not going to retaliate against
you so that's the spirit that Martin
Luther King is calling for at another
point he says that the means the ways in
which this is done must be as pure as
the ends that it doesn't make any sense
to try to pursue a great end
mainly racial justice which includes a
sense of reconciliation of brotherhood
of human beings of recognizing people
for the persons that they are and not
just by skin color you know aiming for
that you know judging people by the
content of the character rather than the
color of their skin all of that is the
end and Martin Luther King is saying
that the means that they not that the
means by which they have to pursue that
have to be as good have to be as pure
have to be as nonviolent as those ends
so that precludes any sort of well in
this case it's justified for me to kick
that guy in this case it's justified for
me to shoot somebody else in return he
talks about creative tension this is a
really important idea involved in
nonviolent protest nonviolent action in
the face of injustice and we're going to
come back to that when we look at this
diagram I want to talk a little bit more
though about this notion that he has
really i says non-violent direct action
seeks to create a crisis and foster such
attention that a community which is
constantly refused to negotiate so
negotiation is network is forced to
confront the issue how so it seeks to so
to dramatize the issue that it can no
longer be ignored now what does it mean
to dramatize an issue to inject drama
and it doesn't mean that you know
everybody should like you know make up
some big stories and you know inflate
things know what it means is the the the
streets literally become a stage
everything becomes part of a human drama
everybody exists in one big fishbowl
where other people are looking on and
seeing the action that's taking place
the Lord Rama originally comes by the
way from the word for action Aristotle
talks about this in his poetics and King
knows this because he's actually
studying these things when he was in
college and divinity school himself as
we know actually from reading his is a
those papers that he wrote so to
dramatize this means that there's going
to be an oppressive force that has been
oppressive all this time and now other
people are standing up and saying we're
going to be the victims we're going to
be the victims because we're going to
confront them the people who have said
no to us over and over and over again
and we're going to say you should be
saying yes you should be letting us do
what we need to do you should be
treating us as equals you should not be
oppressing us you should actually be
doing the opposite of that and then
they're going to get attacked and this
happens in the eyes of the community not
only the local community but also the
national community so they want to have
this publicized why do they have the
name is publicized not to make a big
deal of themselves but so that they can
be in a role where they are actually
being seen as what they are an oppressed
victim standing up against prejudice and
oppression and being beaten down they
want to provoke something on the part of
the audience namely a crisis of
conscience a saying this is wrong we
shouldn't be going along with this I
didn't I didn't know the things were
this bad that's sort of reaction that's
what nonviolent direct action is
supposed to be doing it's not just
saying your piece it's not just coming
out and marching around and you know
engaging in sort of that kind of drama
it's actually doing a sort of play in
which one ends up being the main
character but it's in a certain sense of
tragedy he talks about in the I have a
dream speech talks about this as well
he's got this wonderful line about
meeting physical force with soul force
and he says we must conduct our struggle
on the high plane of dignity and
discipline and once again that self
purification is a matter of introducing
discipline rather than being sort of an
undisciplined rabble just rising up and
saying we're not going to take this
let's throw some bottles let's break
some windows it's it's requiring an
awful lot of discipline to stand up to
oppression when you know that you're
probably going to be on the wrong side
of the nightstick so the high plane of
dignity not allowing the people who are
trying to keep them from having dignity
to impose it upon them not allowing
themselves to degenerate to the level of
those who just use fraud or force or
fear or intimidation says we must not
allow our creative protest to degenerate
into physical violence again and again
we must rise to the majestic heights of
meeting physical force with soul force
and King goes on to say that in that
speech and also in the letter that this
doesn't just mean not getting physically
violent with people and the not getting
physically violent doesn't mean that one
doesn't you know say you know resist
being taken away by it by laying still
or it doesn't it doesn't mean that one
can't get in between an oppressor and
their victim just means that one is not
actually engaging in aggression but it's
also possible to to mess this up by the
way one feels and King thinks that you
know it's difficult but one has some
control over how one feels by by
thinking about the way one frames things
so he goes on and he says you know the
marvelous new militancy militancy which
is engulfed the Negro community must not
lead us to distrust all white people so
distrust is one of those things hatred
bitterness he talks about these meeting
physical force of soul force requires
that one actually try to rid oneself of
these these negative emotions which is
very hard to do and certainly not to act
on those emotions towards the
other as those emotions would have won
want to now let's talk about tension
again he says you know we want to
dramatize the issue negotiation
nonviolent direct action is supposed to
create a crisis after negotiation fails
and foster such a tension that a
community which is constantly refused to
negotiate is forced to confront the
issue and it's word tension is king
feels almost kind of a dirty word so
whoever is introducing tension is really
causing a lot of trouble and he talks a
lot about the power structure the power
structure run being over simplistic here
I know that there's class distinctions
and all that but I want to keep this
very simple the power structure in short
and segregation is whites are on top
blacks are on the bottom and and you
know how does this maintained by force
coming down this way right there's also
you know to some degree a alienation
process that happens down here that
we'll talk about in a moment but for the
most part what keeps this in place is
power going down and it can be physical
power you know the threat of physical
force it can be economic power the
threat of losing one's precarious
economic existence it can be social
power it can be all sorts of modes of
power but power is imposed and this
introduces a certain tension attention
which is not felt by the people who are
on top so they can say all you're
introducing tension into it but that
tension is there the whole time because
anytime that you're placing people under
duress you're introducing tension into
the system so one of the other King says
my citing the create the creation of
tension as part of the work of the
nonviolent resistor may sound rather
shocking but I must confess I'm not
afraid of the word tension I earnestly
opposed violent tension what is vile
attention
this where the tension has to do
basically when for you know think to
yourself about you know a mechanism in
which a spring is compressed down and if
you know the lever goes suddenly that
spring will shoot forth that's violent
tension tension can lead to things
actually breaking if they can't bend far
enough or if they become brittle because
of being kept under too much tension
sometimes when the tension is released
the spring can't come forth all the way
to but this is the violent attention
that King says is already there he says
there is a constructive nonviolent
tension which is necessary for growth
that sort of tension is going to come
from below and it's going to involve all
of these or at least some of them more
and more as the struggle goes on so he
says the purpose of our direct action
program is to create a situation so
crisis packed that it will inevitably
open the door to negotiation and he
talks here about monologue and dialogue
the goal against Italy into negotiation
by introducing a different kind of
tension there this kind of tension just
makes people anxious makes them willing
to use force against each other makes
them willing to perpetuate injustice
against each other creative tension
treats people as fully human beings
here's the thing you know when it comes
to that to treat another person as a
human being is not always to say yeah
you're a-okay the way that you are if
that person is involved in things that
are destructive to themselves or to
others to treat them as a human being is
actually to call them on that and say
look at what you're doing look what the
effects are on these other people do you
want to be like that and
asking them do you want to be like that
or do you want something better you're
actually treating them as a human person
to convict them in that sense as the the
word goes to convict somebody's
conscience he goes ahead and he talks a
bit more about tension a little bit
later on he says that he's talking about
white moderates and unfortunately white
moderates have gone along with this this
system the segregationists can be
counted on to just keep the power
structure in place because you know they
want to keep segregation a reality but
then there's this whole body of the
white moderates that King says I filled
it very disappointed in them because
they don't want to see the tensions that
are there so i hope the white moderate
would understand that the present
tension in the south is a necessary
phase of the transition from an
obnoxious negative piece in which the
negro passively accept it is unjust
quite to the substantive and positive
peace in which all men will respect the
dignity and worth of human personality
he's talking there about the ultimate
goal that we're going to talk about more
in one of the other videos about racial
justice so the white moderates are
unwilling to see that the violent
tensions that that's there and when a
new tension is introduced the creative
tension live down here by those who have
been oppressed actually saying that's
enough and you know we want to end this
this situation the way moderates don't
want to to go along with that than they
reject it they support the
segregationist thereby so he says what
we want to do is bring the surface this
hidden cash ins we want people to see
this for what it is we want them to
recognize that there is a power
structure in place that is you know
imposing power downward from those who
are on top
to those who are placed on the bottom
who don't deserve to be at the Bob we do
this by bringing up a creative attention
from below so he says we bring it out
into the open where it can be seen and
dealt with like a boil that can never be
cured so long as it is covered up but
must be open with its ugliness to the
natural medicines of air in life
injustice must be exposed with all the
tension its exposure creates to the
light of human conscience and the air of
national opinion before it can be cured
so again that is what non-violent action
is supposed to do to introduce this
creative tension by making people look
at what is actually happening by showing
them what you know the power structure
is doing and by also showing them what
other people who aren't in the power
structure are doing and what they're
suffering as a result you notice I've
got a few other things down here as well
King talks about nonviolent resistance
as beating in between two extremes in
between the extreme of accommodating and
an extreme position of violent
resistance to oppression we're going to
talk a little bit more about this a
little bit in another video but the
accommodating people are the ones who
have been suffering and they have gotten
so beaten down that even though there is
this tension even though they're a force
to absorb most of the damage that this
tension imposes they don't want things
to get worse and so they're not happy
about seeing any sort of protest the
other you know the other possibility is
of saying well let's use violence
against violence let's use counter
violence if they're going to use
aggression against us let's use
aggression against them and King says
that that's not actually going to work
for the one thing these guys have more
force so if you want to make it just a
matter of four
course they're probably going to win for
another thing remember what non-violent
action was supposed to do dramatization
of the situation how do things look from
the outside when you have people who are
saying let's just use violence you know
if they're going to Lynch us let's Lynch
them if they're going to destroy our
shops let's destroy their shops well
when other people look at it from the
outside they're not going to align
themselves with with this way of
protesting and they're going to say see
those are those are the bad guys let's
keep them down nonviolent resistance has
the possibility of actually bringing in
other people of making them see yeah I
shouldn't be a moderate this is actually
wrong I need to take a position and
support the civil rights struggle
perhaps pacifying this group perhaps
empowering this group perhaps even
reaching some of the segregationists
eventually and we're gonna want some of
the other White's start saying boyer you
know you're really too far with this
sort of stuff maybe they start to become
insecure and they start to say maybe I
am wrong about this maybe I need to look
at what I'm doing and eventually it can
lead to a radically changed situation
but King thinks that this is only really
possible when all of these other things
are kept in mind that if the nonviolent
movement becomes violent that it will
just replicate the same sort of
oppression as it's fighting against